tag zusammen herzlich willkommen zu zdf
heute live eurem ihren live stream zu
aktuellen ereignissen und diskussionen
wir haben uns zu viel über 2020 lustig
gemacht und als wir dachten das hat das
ist einfach so einen großen busen bruder
geholt viel spaß mit 2021 so hat das
gestern der twitter comedian eine hot so
zusammengefasst womit wir es gerade zu
tun haben und er hat damit finde ich
ziemlich gut die lage auf den punkt
getroffen wir fragen uns nämlich auch in
der redaktion in jeden tag was ist hier
eigentlich los
also wir haben die masken affäre in der
cdu/csu wir haben ein impfchaos wir
haben lockerungen trotz steigender
infektionszahlen wir haben also ziemlich
viel zu besprechen
und wir fragen uns sind die lockerungen
vielleicht auch zu früh gekommen und das
möchten wir besprechen mit michael
kretschmer ministerpräsident in sachsen
mitglied des cdu präsidiums und
natürlich mit euch und euren fragen und
kommentaren wie immer in die dafür
vorgesehenen kommentarspalten oder an
zdf heute.de zdf.de ich werde sehen was
ich davon mit in das gespräch mit herrn
kretschmann kretzschmar einnehmen kann
und den begrüße ich jetzt in dresden
hallo herr kretschmann
guten abend größe ja auch sie haben in
den letzten konferenz von
ministerpräsidentinnen und
bundesregierung eine protokollnotiz
unten an den beschluss an diese sind
dann dieses lange dokument einfügen
lassen
ich ziehe das mal der freistaat sachsen
hält die hier beschlossenen
unkonditionierte öffnungen angesichts
der aktuellen und absehbaren infektions
lage für nicht vertretbar heißt es da
und sachsen sei der ansicht dass
öffnungen mit einem verpflichtenden und
funktionierenden test regime gekoppelt
sein müssen das muss man kurz vielleicht
erklären so eine protokollnotiz ist so
was wie eine klare ansage wir tragen das
mit aber nur unter protest
jetzt ist das ganze genau zwei wochen
her wie würden sie diese protokollnotiz
heute formulieren ja sie hat leider eine
bittere realität erhalten wir haben das
damals gesehen wir sind ja viel dem
gespräch mit virologen
trotzdem der wunsch der bevölkerung der
unternehmerinnen unternehmen der
gastronom war halt riesig groß und ich
kann das auch nachvollziehen dass man da
versucht ein stück weit auch probier's
doch mal
aber es ist letzten endes der zweite und
dritte schritt vor dem ersten gemacht
worden
wir haben eben nicht diese test
kapazitäten wir haben nicht diese
sicheren kontakte und deswegen haben wir
jetzt eine steigende instanz und das ist
sehr gefährlich wir müssen jetzt aus
meiner sicht die richtigen schlüsse aus
dieser entwicklung ziehen bevor wir
darüber weiterreden und ins detail gehen
weil da gibt es viel zu besprechen und
wollen wir noch mal kurz zusammenfassen
was da beschlossen wurde vor zwei wochen
das hat mein kollege jan friedrich
fischer für uns getan
seit anfang märz gibt es ihn den
stufenplan für die krone lockerung
buchhandlung blumenläden oder etwa
gartenmärkte dürfen demnach wieder
öffnen
bei niedrigen regionalen zahlen sollen
einzelhändler mit einschränkungen
nachziehen genau wie museen oder etwa
zur die bedingung die inzidenz liegt
unter 100 zudem sind weitere lockerungen
im zwei-wochen-rhythmus vorgesehen
steigen die zahlen hingegen geht zurück
auf anfang eine notbremse greift soweit
alle einig nicht wirklich sachsen
vermerkte noch im beschlusspapier des
letzten corona gipfels der freistaat
hält die hier beschlossenen
unkonditionierte öffnungen angesichts
der aktuellen und absehbaren infektions
lage sowie im quote für nicht vertretbar
bedenken geäußert und doch oder auch in
sachsen gelockert beispiel chemnitz hier
war das shoppen oder der besuch im
tierpark wieder möglich zumindest mit
termin doch die stadt muss jetzt
zurückrudern
die inzidenz liegt seit drei tagen über
100 auch in den sächsischen schulen
rumort ist zwar kehrten die älteren
schüler in dieser woche zurück doch der
neustart verlief schleppend es hatte bei
den tests hinzu kommen die hohen
inzidenz werte die klassenräume könnten
daher schneller als gedacht wieder leer
sein
ja wir haben es gerade schon gehört und
gesagt herr kretschmer sie haben eine
protokollnotiz anfügen lassen haben
quasi gesagt wir stimmen zu unter
protest warum konnten sie sich denn
damals nicht durchsetzen mit ihrer sicht
ja weil der wunsch so groß ist und wenn
wir jetzt mal genau in die bevölkerung
hinein hören dann hören wir immer noch
diesen dringenden wunsch zum öffnen wir
haben jetzt begonnen schulen wieder zu
schließen wie auch in anderen
bundesländern
und sie merken bei den eltern bei den
kindern bei den bürgermeistern die
wollen das überhaupt nicht die wollen
gerne dass die schulen offen bleiben
also das eine ist die situation wie wir
sie wahrnehmen und wie sie virologen
auch beschreiben und das andere ist die
wahrnehmung der bevölkerung deswegen ist
ganz wichtig dass wir in den kommenden
tagen wir haben ja etwas zeit weil die
krankenhäuser leer sind aber man darf
das ist auch nicht so lange laufen dass
ein bisschen alle voll sind dass wir
wirklich neben der inzidenz auch ganz
deutlich zeigen schaut es ist die
krankenhaus bewegung die medizinische
versorgung ist sie wird immer
schwieriger immer mehr menschen werden
eingeliefert und deswegen ist es
zwingend zu handeln und wir haben ja
auch optionen die wir jetzt vor uns
haben wir müssen dürfen das nur nicht
laufen lassen also stellen sich mir
mehrere fragen also einmal die frage
hören sie vielleicht da auf die falschen
weil das denn ich so rein gucke in die
filter blasen denen nicht so folge dann
höre ich da er menschen die sagen nicht
aufmachen schickt die kinder nicht in
die schulen haltet das noch länger durch
ich habe sorgen um meine eltern um mich
um meine gesundheit also hört er die
politik vielleicht immer auf die
falschen das ist die eine frage wenn wir
auch gucken die umfragen vom zum
beispiel vom zdf politbarometer gibt es
immer noch eine verhältnismäßig große
zustimmung zu den maßnahmen es gibt auch
stimmen die sagen es muss schärfer
werden und auf der anderen seite die die
sie es gerade angesprochen haben sind
sie vielleicht einfach leicht sie nicht
haben die vergessen was im dezember in
sachsen los war
also wenn sie sich die grundschulen
anschauen dort ist die schul
besuchspflicht ausgesetzt und 95 prozent
der kinder sind da
das heißt die eltern stimmen einfach
damit auch ab ich hatte heute eine
konferenz mit allen bürgermeistern im
märz
bürger einhelliges meinungsspektrum
lasst die schulen offen und ich habe
sehr intensiv auch argumentiert ich kann
das nicht versprechen wir müssen uns das
genau anschauen der gesundheitsschutz
ist ja sehr wichtig ich glaube dass es
da einen großen riss gibt und die
diskussionslage ist da nicht eindeutig
aber eindeutig ist die entwicklung wie
sie sich gerade vollzieht und deswegen
glaube ich müssen wir darüber sprechen
was ist die voraussetzung dass bei einer
pandemie die sich immer weiter auftürmt
durch diese mutationen die wesentlich
ansteckender ist der tatsache dass der
impfstoff nicht in der masse zur
verfügung steht zumindest kurzfristig um
eine immunisierung der bevölkerung zu
erreichen was haben wir an instrumenten
und das haben wir in dieser protokoll
die erklärung auch formuliert das ist
das testen und das jetzt klug
auszurollen in den nächsten tagen und
wochen sehr konsequent ist eine
möglichkeit dass wir trotzdem viele
freiheiten bekommen
dieser beschluss der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ist ja
einen stufenplan
es war der wunsch der bevölkerung doch
zu einer eine perspektive zu haben und
mir geht es darum diese perspektive
nicht zu zerstören sondern sie zu
ermöglichen und dafür müssen uns jetzt
die instrumente geben aber wenn wir auch
einen stufenplan gucken stellen wir fest
es gibt immer mehr landkreise in
deutschland teilweise auch bundesländer
die diese zum beispiel diesen notbremse
sehr großzügig auslegen die auch sagen
das geht jetzt hier nicht oder das geht
erst später dh der stufenplan ist auch
eigentlich ad acta gelegt oder also aus
meiner sicht ist wenn man die situation
jetzt vernünftig analysiert sagen diese
ganze dieses experiment ist gescheitert
jetzt ist das alles vergossene milch
warum das gewesen ist und nicht ich will
mal sagen wenn wir uns in die
bevölkerung reinhören am dritten märz
war der wunsch übermächtig genau diesen
weg zu gehen aber es ist auch jetzt erst
einmal gleich jetzt ist die frage was
folgt daraus aus meiner sicht folgt
erstens daraus jetzt keine weiteren
lockerungen das kann man nicht machen
wenn man sieht dass der weg den man
eingeschlagen ist nicht der richtige ist
zweiter
das haben sie angesprochen diese 100 ist
nicht aus der luft gegriffen sondern sie
ist ein eine maximale ausdehnung was
vernünftig ist wir hatten im vergangen
ja hier in sachsen eine instanz im
sommer von fünf nie war sie höher als 5
in vielen wochen war sie sogar unter 1
das war die voraussetzung für diese
große freiheit die wir hatten und wir
wissen dass bei einer instituts von 100
das erleben wir übrigens jetzt auch
gerade nicht das ganze system stabil ist
sondern die zahlen schießen nach oben
durch deswegen überall da wo die 100
überschritten ist muss es diese
konsequenzen geben das tun wir hier in
sachsen das tun viele andere auch und
die das nicht tun
die müssen wir auch ansprechen weil das
ist ein sehr gefährlicher weg sie haben
sachsen erwähnt über das jahreswechsel
hatten wir eine instanz von 460 eine
wirklich schwierige situation in den
krankenhäusern
das müssen wir jetzt verhindern und
deswegen die 100 ist wichtiger dass
dritter schritt was ich gerade gesagt
habe der zweite und dritte schritt den
wir vor dem ersten gemacht haben
der erste schritt muss nachgeholt werden
und das ist dieses sichere test regime
ich gucke mal bei uns in die kommentare
das ist ein wichtiger bestandteil auch
von unserer sendung und und sehe da
gerade auch was diesen incidents wert
angeht die sie gerade angesprochen haben
diese 100 auch bei uns im clip auf
youtube sehr viel skepsis also ich nehme
mal zum beispiel oliver krügel auf
facebook der schreibt sehr geehrter herr
ministerpräsident uns als bevölkerung
würde einmal ohne ihre ausweichenden
aussagen interessieren was ist bei 100
was wird dann zugemacht warum deuten
dass jetzt wieder alle anders bei allem
respekt so glaubt ihm keiner mehr
das können sie daher in krügel antworten
ja bei 100 das ist ja nach einem
gewissen zeit drei tage und dann noch
mal zwei werktage wir müssen bei uns im
freistaat sachsen die körpernahen
dienstleistungen wieder schließen und
kulturelle einrichtungen so wie sie es
beschrieben haben
und wir müssen darüber sprechen ob
schule weiter möglich ist oder nicht in
vielen fällen wird dann auch schule und
kindergarten wieder in denen not betrieb
gehen die entscheidende frage ist
vielleicht warum ist das eigentlich mit
der 100 so wichtig ich habe heute den
ganzen tag nur die frage gestellt
bekommen ist 100 eigentlich die richtige
zahl und meine erfahrung ist mit 100
passiert folgendes erstens die
krankenhäuser füllen sich langsam
das kann man sehen und wer einen offenen
blick dafür hat der wird das auch zur
kenntnis nehmen 200 ist eine grenze
erreicht bei der wirklich die
gesundheitsämter die kontakt nach
verfolgung nicht mehr realisieren können
weil es eine große anzahl von fällen ist
und hinter diesen fällen dann auch viele
kontaktpersonen stehen und deswegen ist
die 100 keine stabile zahl ich kenne
keinen fall wo das jetzt mal über eine
längere zeit immer um die 95 100 105
gependelt ist sondern ich habe kennedy
nur fälle sagen wo bei 100 oder bei 95
es am ende auf 140 auf 204 300 immer
weiter gegangen ist und dann haben sie
wirklich eine überlastung des
gesundheitssystems innerhalb von einigen
wochen deswegen ist diese 100 schon eine
eine zahl die kann man wenn man kritisch
ist gerne nochmal spiegel mit der
krankenhaus situation das ist vielleicht
auch mal ein gewisser weise beruhigen
vielleicht ist es auch jetzt gerade noch
mal die zeit dass mit der bevölkerung
auch so zu diskutieren was macht das in
den krankenhäusern und deswegen musste
das passieren
aber unsere erfahrung ist dass genau das
passiert aber trotzdem stellt sich hier
die frage die auch herr krügel hier
formuliert hat warum deuten dass wieder
alle anders also warum sagt die stadt
können zum beispiel ja wir gucken erst
noch mal andere sagen zum beispiel die
stadt hamburg die hansestadt hamburg hat
gesagt ja bei 100 machen wir alle
dienstleistungen zu aber schulen und
kitas bleiben offen weil wir haben
testungen und dann muss man sagen die
kinder werden einmal die woche getestet
lehrer und lehrerinnen zweimal die woche
da kann man jetzt auch die frage stellen
was ausreichend ist also das scheint ja
wieder jeder für sich selber anders
auszulegen und da kommt dann ja doch ein
großer teil der des unwillens oder der
verunsicherung der bevölkerung her wenn
man irgendwie doch machen kann was man
möchte
na ja es hat auch was mit dem
erfahrungshorizont zu tun wir haben halt
gesehen auch auf dramatische weise was
passiert wenn die krankenhäuser
überlastet sind und deswegen sind wir
hier besonders vorsichtig und das heißt
die anderen ministerpräsidentin müssen
erstmal diese erfahrung machen was
passiert wenn die krankenhäuser
volllaufen sind sie sind ja jetzt schon
schlauer
ich hoffe nicht dass wir diese erfahrung
machen müssen und das ist in sachsen im
vergangenen jahr auch nur deswegen gut
gegangen weil in den
anderen regionen ganz viele betten frei
waren also sind patienten ausgeflogen
nach lübeck nach schwerin
und das ist eine wirklich dramatische
situation gewesen die uns das stimmt
schon
besonders vorsichtig sein lässt bevor
wir jetzt weiter sprechen gerade über
diese instanz zahl nochmals sie haben
gesagt sie den ganzen tag mussten sie
schon diese 100 verteidigen gucken erst
noch mal die aktuellen zahlen an weil
die sind ja doch wichtig und auch
teilweise besorgniserregend deutschland
vor zwei wochen die sieben tage
incidents lag bundesweit bei 64 in
sachsen bei 77,2 die menschen hofften
auf fallende zahlen und mögliche öffnung
schritte
doch die zahlen stiegen stetig wieder an
zuletzt lag die inzidenz bundesweit bei
rund 86 besonders betroffen ist auch
sachsen mit über 100 hier gibt es mit
dem vogtlandkreis bundesweit den
zweithöchsten wert so also sachsen ist
auch schon wieder teilweise richtig
schlimm dran
ich schaue noch mal in die kommentare
also zum beispiel maximilian thomas
möchte wissen war es nicht völlig
absehbar dass das ganze nicht oder
mindestens noch nicht funktioniert und
wenn ja warum wurde und wird dann noch
gelockert da haben sie gesagt so ein
experiment das ist gescheitert aber er
fragt sie was halten sie als
ministerpräsident davon zumindest in der
korona pandemie einmal den chinesischen
weg zu gehen ich deutlich dass man jetzt
so dass maximilian meint also wirklich
kompletten lockdown teilweise menschen
dürfen nicht nur aus ihren häusern
müssen zwei woche sich einsperren
wenn der inzidenz wert steigt damit dann
die pandemie unter kontrolle ist
naja china ist schon sehr drastisch was
dort gemacht worden ist ich glaube dass
niemand von uns wir sind eine demokratie
und ein rechtsstaat aber was dahinter
steckt ist ja einmal ganz konsequent
auch die realwirtschaft und andere
bereiche und das finde ich sollten wir
deutschland ersparen weil auch jetzt
schon sich abzeichnet dass andere länder
möglicherweise viel stärker aus dieser
krise herauskommen auch die versorgung
mit impfstoff spielte eine große rolle
wir müssen dafür sorgen dass die
industrie vor allen dingen diejenigen
die exportieren weiter am laufen sind
damit wir nicht noch stärker betroffen
sind wir leisten viele eine
unterstützung es ist ein großes problem
dass diese wirtschaftshilfe sehr spät
gekommen sind sehr bürokratisch waren
das hat vielen menschen die kraft und
auch den glauben geraubt aber ich finde
wir sollten es versuchen ohne diese
drastischen mittel aber wir haben schon
ein jahr habe ich einen punkt ja wir tun
ist ein jahr wir sind damit
erfolgreicher als tschechien polen
frankreich oder andere länder wie china
von einer dritten märz aus meiner wäre
china ist erfolgreicher als die neuesten
werk herzustellen
ich hab's nicht verstanden wer das
erfolgreich ist wie die chinesen das war
ja die frage dass des zuschauers die
chinesen die chinesen er hat ja erfolg
sagt ich glaub ja gut aber kommen die
chinesen also ich glaube das hört man
beiseite schieben in china sind die
leute weg gesperrt worden
eine woche war die wohnung zu dann
durften die mal wieder raus kann hat
sich um die leute gekümmert
das wollen wir nicht dass es auch nicht
das maß der mittel sondern wir müssen
jetzt dafür sorgen und ich würde mal
sagen nicht so rum experimentieren
sondern jetzt mal sich die situation
wirklich vergegenwärtigen was ist
notwendig wenn man eine immunisierung
der bevölkerung schnell nicht erreicht
hat man doch aber jetzt seit ungefähr
zwei wochen durch diese schnelltests
auch wirklich die möglichkeit dieses
instrument anzuwenden
die tests sind da sie sind verträglich
sind auch zu einigermaßen vernünftigen
preisen erreichbar der bund übernimmt
die finanzierung also ist doch klar
jetzt bauen wir überall in allen
gemeinden diese tests zentren auf lassen
uns eine vernünftige app anwendung
organisieren und dann ist der besuch von
gastronomie von hotellerie von der sport
von kultur beim einkaufen möglich wenn
man ein negatives testergebnis hat das
ist doch jetzt ein weg der plausibel ist
der möglich ist unter dem übrigens auch
schule sicher organisiert werden kann
und ich würde einfach sagen lasst uns
auf diesem weg machen und dafür ein
gemeinsames gesellschaftliches
verständnis organisieren dass das eine
möglichkeit sein kann
jetzt muss ich mal kurz den kollegen
hier bescheid sagen weil wir wollten
eigentlich noch über herrn günther
sprechender heute auch eine
pressekonferenz gegeben hat
das zeige ich ihnen gleich was da gesagt
hat denn sie haben das gerade das
stichwort gegeben diese testzentren also
es gibt ja schon einen testlauf in
tübingen wo quasi ist viele testzentrum
gibt und damit kann man dann wenn man
negativ getestet ist zum beispiel wieder
in die gastronomie gehen
das sächsische dorf augustusburg wollten
ähnlichen testlauf machen ist ein ganz
kleines dorf mit wenigen tausend
einwohnern durfte aber nicht weil der
incidents wert zu hoch war
der bürgermeister von augustusburg ist
von der spd und der war darüber nicht
amüsiert und ich hoffe die kollegen
konnten jetzt schnell genug umbauen und
uns den aufstieg jetzt zeigen wir haben
derzeit eine orts incidents von 220 das
ist also keine erlauben zahlen wenn ich
die aber anders und sage dass wir 4512
einwohner sind und zehn fälle reichen
diesen wert zu erreichen dann wissen sie
was ich meine also wir müssen weg von
dieser starren incidents betrachtung
hinzu ja größe und räumen möglicherweise
gerade bei bekleidung und kommunen wie
unsere oder oberwiesenthal unserer
partner im projekt hat 2000 einwohner
da reicht ja die hälfte der zahl um so
ein projekt zu versenken das kann ich
wirklich da legt jetzt ist es natürlich
schwierig dass wir mit einem system was
dafür sorgt das getestete auf getestete
treffen genauso behandelt werden wie der
rest der welt weil dann aber natürlich
kein pilot projekt machen und auch keine
daten sammeln die wir glaube ich
dringend brauchen um uns ja etwas
unabhängiger machen zu können auch
wissenschaftlich belegt unabhängiger
machen zu können von dem zu auf zu auf
zu auf was wir jetzt schon kennen also
können wir alle zusammen nachrechnen im
kleinen dorf mit 4120 sind krank hat man
sofort eine inzidenz wert der in einer
großstadt und problem wäre in einem
kleinen dorf vielleicht nicht so also
wieso muss man das jetzt in diesem fall
tatsächlich so starr sehen und diesen
instanz wert so festnageln das
tatsächlich so ein testlauf nicht mehr
stattfinden kann
na gut sie haben mich die letzten
minuten danach gefragt warum leute diese
klaren regeln die aufgestellt worden
sind dann für sich anders interpretieren
aber ich will mal sagen ich finde dieses
modellprojekt als ich habe erstmal mit
boris palmer lange gesprochen
was tübing angeht ich habe in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz gemeinsam
mit winfried kretschmann sehr dafür
geworben dass diese modellprojekte
tübingen und andere möglich werden und
ich sehe das was sie jetzt von
augustusburg und oberwiesenthal
beschrieben haben es gibt viele davon
auch in anderen bundesländern als genau
den weg und wir werden das auch
realisieren
ich möchte dafür aber im umfeld haben
das werden wir uns jetzt in den nächsten
tagen auch schaffen und dann soll es
losgehen genau diese beispiele brauchen
wir und dann auch flächendeckend statt
einer generellen kontakt vermeidung oder
eben unsicheren kontakten 50 prozent der
menschen haben keine symptome aber sind
trotzdem ansteckend das ist das problem
eben brauchen wir diese sicheren
kontakte und dieses projekt was sie
beschrieben haben ist genau das und
deswegen wird es auch realisiert werden
auch gerade bei höheren zahlen mit dem
ziel dass wir dann am ende natürlich die
instanzen die infektionszahlen senken
viel testen sorgt zwar im ersten moment
dass die zahl nach oben gehen aber
langfristig ist ein wirklich wirksames
instrument zur bekämpfung der pandemie
aber das hat sich eine frage die zahlen
gehen nach oben das kann dazu führen
dass wieder eventuell notbremse gezogen
werden müssen weil nicht berücksichtigt
wird wie tatsächlich die anzahl der
positiven pcr test steigt weil das ist
ja im grunde viel aussagekräftiger also
wenn wir 100.000 menschen mehr testen
aber die generelle rate der positiven
tests bleibt gleich dann kann man nicht
feststellen dass sich das virus sehr
viel mehr sollte schneller verbreitet
und man stellt fest man findet mehr
leute da ist doch auch wieder ein
problem mit diesem incidents wert dass
das wenn er als einziger wert genommen
wird dann doch irgendwie relativ
angreifbar ist
ja ich meine erfahrung ist es ist ein
ziemlich harter wert ist der von dem
sich in der tat vieles ableiten lässt
aber ich will ehrlich gesagt gar nicht
so drauf rum beharren ich habe auch
meinen leuten hier in sachsen immer
gesagt wir sind da ganz entspannt wir
nehmen die instanz und wir schauen uns
danach an was passiert in den
krankenhäusern und wir haben hier eine
zahl definiert an kurve betten die wir
haben von der wir wissen wenn sie belegt
ist dann leidet die medizinische
versorgung in anderen bereichen was
nicht
sein darf und solange wir diese zahl
nicht erreicht haben können wir auch
etwas freier umgehen aber wir sehen eben
auch jetzt schon dass die betten sich
langsam füllen und mein rat ist sehr
dass wir auch mit der bevölkerung genau
diesen blick haben und vielleicht
solltest du dann auch eher bereit diesen
weg nachzuvollziehen aber die frage ist
ja ob die bevölkerung tatsächlich das so
sieht wie sie wir nicht mal auf den
offenen brief von den bürgermeistern aus
dem erzgebirgskreis schaue der jetzt
auch durch die medien gegangen ist ein
zitat daraus das komplette
undifferenzierte herunterfahren ganzer
branchen oder lebensbereiche über monate
hinweg erweckt mit zunehmender dauer
eher den eindruck einer plan und
hilflosigkeit dann stelle ich fest dass
da zumindest ein kreis nicht mit ihnen
geht und nicht der meinung ist dass man
sich hier sorgen machen muss und die
fordern auch dass man die zusätzlich
ermittelten fälle in ein angemessenes
verhältnis setzt sie haben heute
vormittag mit 60 bürgermeistern aus
ihrem land gesprochen was haben sie
denen gesagt ja dass man da ganz cool
mit der zahl umgehen muss wenn wenn die
incidents nicht die richtige ist und
nicht mehr weil mehr menschen geimpft
worden sind oder weil das jetzt höher
sind dies betrifft nicht am ende zu mehr
versorgung im krankenhaus führt dann
können wir ja auch entspannt sein aber
der blick gerade in dieser region zeigt
eben es ist genauso die
krankenhausbetten füllen sich wieder und
wir haben ein gemeinsames verständnis
dass die medizinische versorgung
gewährleistet werden muss und deswegen
haben wir dann sehr darüber gesprochen
welche instrumente wir haben und sind am
ende beim testen rausgekommen es ist
eben leider nicht so dass diese annahme
zutrifft die älteren sind jetzt geimpft
und die anderen haben nur leichte
verläufe das stimmt nicht
vor allen dingen auch jüngere 50 60
jährige kommen jetzt ins krankenhaus
haben auch diese schweren verläufe so
einfach ist die sache nicht und wir
haben ja die tschechische grenze bei uns
wir brauchen also nur drüber schauen da
gibt es in keiner familie mehr jemanden
der nicht einen menschen verloren hat an
corona dramatische zahlen die dadurch
entstanden sind dass man es laufen hat
lassen jetzt haben wir instanzen von 7
800.000 jetzt über wochen schon das
müssen wir deutschland ersparen aber
sind jetzt die bürgermeister auf ihrem
kurs oder und neben den offenen brief
zurück und meinen man könnte so
weitermachen schulen und kitas sollten
doch geschlossen werden weil das war ja
auch eine forderung schulen und kitas
offen lassen
ja das war die forderung auch glaube ich
am ende des gesprächs ich hoffe ich habe
einige erreicht und sensibilisieren
können
das rkw sagt ganz klar auch wir sehen
das auch das kinderkrippen kindergärten
und auch grundschulen den stärkeren in
der stärkere rolle dieser pandemie
sprechen es im erzgebirge jetzt nicht
gerade ganz deutlich so zu sehen dass
die zahl recht gering
deswegen kann man auch im zweifel da
auch noch mal schauen ob es da noch mal
kompromisse gibt aber gesundheitsschutz
geht vor
und deswegen habe ich bestimmt nicht
jeden überzeugt aber es ist am ende ja
so wir müssen das gespräch führen müssen
versuchen zu überzeugen und alternativen
versuchen aufzustellen
die es immer gibt ich finde zwischen der
alternative alles zu oder das experiment
laufen lassen und die krankenhäuser sind
wieder an der belastungsgrenze ist doch
ein milderes mittel ein kluges system
aufzubauen von tests und das würde ich
gerne probieren aber mit verlaub wenn
wir gucken wie dieses mit dem impfen
läuft also ich gucke jetzt mal hier auch
nochmal auf einen zuschauer äußerung
marion neubert hat per e-mail uns
geschrieben
ich kann nicht verstehen warum nicht auf
teufel komm raus geimpft wird diese
bürokratie ist eine folgenschwere bremse
wenn das so weitergeht werden wir nie zu
dauernden lockerungen kommen da mache
ich mir so ein bisschen sorgen ob das
mit den testungen besser läuft die oft
wittern bei ihnen getestet und und vivi
also wieso das vonstatten gehenden
sachsen naja das lassen sie uns mal
einen kurzen moment beim thema impfen
bleiben also impfen ist alles super
aufgestellt man könnten doppelt so viele
menschen impfen dreimal so viele
menschen impfen
aber es fehlt der impfstoff und das hat
das bundesland sachsen und das hat
eigentlich auch die bundesrepublik
deutschland nicht in der hand wir sind
darauf angewiesen welche lieferungen von
den pharmaunternehmen kommen
und wir sehen das aus amerika keine
lieferung kommen dass indien keine
lieferung kommen dort sind die großen
fabriken
wir sind also sehr auf das
zurückgeworfen was die europäische union
an kapazitäten hat die werden jetzt
ausgebaut ich glaube dass man daraus
auch für die zukunft lernen muss auch in
anderen bereichen
wir müssen als europa auch selbst
handlungsfähig sein dürfen nicht
abhängig sein von anderen bereichen
von daher ist es jetzt kommt alles sah
zenica dazu übrigens aus meiner sicht
eine absolut richtige entscheidung
zuerst zu stoppen
sicherheit geht bei sowas immer vor
und der skandal wäre gewesen ist eine
zulassung im zweifel noch und dann gibt
es probleme die noch vertuscht werden
und es weitergehen wird
nein auch bei dieser kleinen anzahl von
kritischen fällen muss die sache
aufgearbeitet werden das passiert jetzt
und das die voraussetzung dass überhaupt
jemand danach wenn der impfstoff wieder
zugelassen sein sollte selber sich
impfen lässt aber die beschwerde eines
komplexen stoffen da sind der krieg mehr
die höre ich jetzt seit wochen und seit
monaten fast ja ich stelle aber auch
immer wieder fest dass ärzte und
ärztinnen geht hausärzte gibt die sagen
also die auch geimpft haben das ist
alles viel zu bürokratisch ich muss hier
neuen seiten vorlesen dass das alles
teilweise liegen zwischen impfungen
zwischen zwei impfungen 30 minuten war
jakub wird aber es neben der kunden gibt
also das könnte schneller gehen sagen
zumindest kritische ärzten und ärzte
aber es ist zu viel bürokratie da also
diesen vorwurf den können sie nicht
einfach abstreifen und sagen das ist
immer nur nicht genug impfstoff da ja es
ist der limitierende faktor ist der
impfstoff und das wird auch niemand
bestreiten wir haben diese impfzentren
das geht hintereinander weg wir haben
durch astrazeneca und auch die
diskussion darum die das gegen den punkt
dass viele auch ältere menschen dann
immer gefragt haben
ist das wirklich sicher und gespräche
haben wollen aber ansonsten ist er ein
unglaublicher durchsatz es geht
hintereinander weg und wie gesagt wir
könnten doppelt oder dreimal soviel
verhelfen aber der impfstoff ist nicht
da und das lässt sich auch politisch
nicht entscheiden nicht wir haben eine
entscheidung getroffen und die halte ich
für richtig dass wir als starkes auch
reiches land finden sie ein reiches land
uns nicht vor gedrängelt haben das
hätten wir mit sicherheit gekonnt wir
haben uns
mit den anderen ländern in der
europäischen union auf eine linie
gestellt alle krieg kriegen entsprechend
ihrer bevölkerung der impfstoff werde
das kritisiert hat insofern recht als
dass man es anders machen können
aber ich glaube dass es richtig ist dass
wir so agiert haben und auch das ist
eine frage von wochen und wenigen
monaten ende april haben wir sehr große
liefermengen zu erwarten im juni ist die
sache im wesentlichen durch wenn ich
jetzt dramatisches passiert dann auf
jeden fall im august von daher das ende
ist absehbar aber wir wollen ja glaube
ich nicht dass august jetzt in der
jetzigen situation verharren
also müssen wir uns was einfallen lassen
na gut da haben sie jetzt immer gesagt
testen testen testen das lassen sie sich
einfallen das haben sie mir fragen nicht
beantwortet die dann erwachsenen
getestet wird also wie oft werden
schülerinnen und schüler getesteten der
und lehrer getestet wer kann sich
freiwillig testen lassen und wie läuft
das ab
also schon seit dem schuljahresbeginn im
vergangenen jahr haben alle lehrer das
recht sich einmal die woche testen zu
lassen das machen viele auch jetzt ist
es zu einer pflicht geworden einmal die
woche auch kindergärtnerinnen und
kindergärtner schüler werden seit dieser
woche getestet ab der siebten klasse
das ist das problem dass die tests für
kinder die jünger sind also eigentlich
null bis sechste klasse nicht geeignet
sind und das müssen wir jetzt über die
osterferien klären wie das geht weil
eben in diesem bereich ein besonderes
infektionsgeschehen ist möglicherweise
muss man den wechsel unterricht gehen
müssen die gruppen kleiner werden oder
man muss das testmaterial einsetzen auch
wenn man weiß dass es nicht 100
prozentig ergebnisse bringt aber der
wunsch und da habe ich ein anderes bild
als sie es jetzt vermittelt haben aber
das will das nicht sagen dass es falsch
ist wäre es gibt verschiedene
sichtweisen der wunsch dass kindergärten
offen sind dass schulen offen sind ist
von den eltern so übermächtig und er ist
aus meiner sicht auch für sie physische
gesundheit psychische gesundheit von
kindern von familien so extrem wichtig
dass wir uns doch etwas einfallen lassen
müssen aber auch da gilt nicht einfach
wie der für die forderung seien sie doch
mal mutig sondern das ganze muss
überlegt passieren auch gut abgewägt
werden und muss sich auf einem halb
sicheren fundament bewegen ja ich habe
ja genau über den kommentar gerade offen
der kann jetzt zufällig rein können wir
kurz auf meinen rechner schalten von
marcel hab ich da schreibt ich verstehe
immer noch nicht bei dem ganzen gerede
von vorsichtsmaßnahmen warum die schulen
offen sind also diese stimmen lese ich
immer wieder
und die sind da und wir sehen sie gerade
sagen einmal die woche wird getestet bei
lehrerinnen und lehrern
das ist doch wirklich nicht viel herr
krieg schwer das ist doch gerade bei so
ein test besser schnell fest er hat eine
aussagekraft und maximal 24 stunden und
den restlichen sechs tage laufen die
lehrerinnen und lehrer ungetestet durch
durch volle klassen teilweise in engen
lehrerzimmern und setzten sich wieder
einem risiko aus also dann müsste es
doch eigentlich eine tägliche testungen
geben also jetzt reden wir mal über die
abschlussklassen da gibt es nahezu keine
fälle ganz ganz wenige sie wir haben den
wechsel unterricht bei den größeren
schülern
sie haben bei den größeren schülern auf
die situation dass sie ihren mund und
nasenschutz und auch abstand dass man
das auch durchsetzen kann
von daher glaube ich ist das ein dass
das eine und das andere ist die frage
mit den kleinen kindern wo es keinen
zugelassenen test gibt aber die frage da
war der wohl ich habe ist warum wird
nicht mehr getestet einmal die woche ist
eigentlich zu wenig ja einmal die woche
ist mehr als in vielen anderen bereichen
bisher überhaupt möglich war und die die
anzahl wird auch mit sicherheit erhöht
werden müssen das ist überhaupt keine
frage
aber jetzt wollen wir mal der sache auf
den grund gehen diese selbsttest die
auch minimalinvasiv sind die man
vermutlich auch als staat vorschreiben
kann einem arbeitnehmer das sie tun muss
ja die gibt es seit zehn tagen alles
andere an diese unsäglich langen
stäbchen
wir haben viele ich habe oft solche der
schnelltest machen müssen
das ist etwas was sie nicht zur regel
machen können da gibt es auch genügend
gerichtsurteile und von daher glaube ich
sind wir jetzt haben wir neue
instrumente in der hand die wir jetzt
auch einsetzen müssen
es gibt hier viele fragen noch an sie
herr krieg mehr da kann ich nicht alle
vorlesen da bitte ich um entschuldigung
ja also wir es noch viele detailfragen
dabei ich würde jetzt auch gerne mal von
dieser diskussion
nochmal wegkommen weil es gibt ja eine
große diskussion im bund wie geht's
jetzt weiter also wir werden es wieder
nächste woche gemeinsam erleben dass
ministerpräsident innen und
bundesregierungen zusammensitzen dass
wir noch ein impf gipfel geben also auch
da wird sich eine diskussion geben wie
geht es weiter und daniel günther ihr
kollege in schleswig-holstein
ministerpräsident hat holstein hat einer
pressekonferenz heute gegeben und hat
dort folgendes gesagt wir wollen uns
dafür einsetzen dass reisen innerhalb
von deutschland möglich ist und dass
beherbergungsbetriebe in schleswig
holstein und damit auch in ganz
deutschland in eingeschränktem maße auch
geöffnet haben dürfen
dafür werden wir uns einsetzen wie wir
das in schleswig-holstein umsetzen
werden wir dann unmittelbar nach montag
auch entscheiden
ich glaube dass das auch ein wichtiger
schritt ist weil ich fest davon
überzeugt bin
das ist in diesen zeiten aus allen
möglichen gründen sinnvoller ist seinen
urlaub oder mal eine auszeit auch in
diesen pandemie kreis diesen pandemie
zeiten in seinem umfeld zu genießen im
eigenen land ist es allemal sinnvoller
als jetzt nach mallorca mit gesamt
europa zusammen auf einer insel zu
verbringen
daher würden sie ihren bürgern empfehlen
bürgerinnen und bürgern empfehlen aus
landkreisen mit hohem inzidenz zahlen
nach schleswig holstein zu reisen
auch ich liebe schleswig holstein die
nordsee und noch eigentlich noch ein
bisschen mehr die ostsee gebe ich zu und
wir hatten uns auch für ostern
vorgenommen in die alpen zu fahren und
mal noch mal zu wandern
aber sie haben das vogtland angesprochen
damit seiner incidents von über 300 das
ist entstanden durch eintrag aus den
nachbarregionen hof wunsiedel
tirschenreuth und greiz und deswegen
wenn sie diese virus mutation und die
hoch incidents gebiete richtig über
deutschland verteilen wollen dann müssen
sie ordentlich urlaub zu lassen
und ich glaube damit ergibt sich die
antwort so bitter wie das ist ich glaube
dass es keine gute idee ist
das heißt es werden sie ihrem kollegen
dann auch bei der nächsten gelegenheit
so deutlich sagen
glaub du spinnst wer das weiß er auch
ich meine das sein bestimmt das
bewusstsein und das bedeutet dass in
einer region mit einer niedrigen instanz
des verständnis für diese maßnahmen noch
niedriger ist als das was ich jetzt ja
auch heute auch vormittag erlebt habe in
einer region mit einer instanz von 140
ich kann das alles nachvollziehen aber
am ende ist es die frage wie kommen wir
auf ein sicheres modell und da hat
daniel günther ja was kluges gesagt wir
brauchen ein system in dem wir sicher
sind also all jene die einen wirklich
negativen corona test haben die
regelmäßig getestet werden
die sollen dann auch die möglichkeit
haben viele angebote zu haben auch für
den urlaub ob das jetzt unmittelbar in
den nächsten wochen sein muss oder ob
man das sich für die nächsten wochen
vornimmt ist eine andere frage wir haben
im vergangenen jahr himmelfahrt geöffnet
war einer instanz von ungefähr fünf wir
sind heute viel viel höher und deswegen
würde ich zur vorsicht mahnen jetzt
möchten wir noch einmal über die sache
mit dem bund reden also wir stellen ja
fest die länder haben die hoheit in der
pandemie bekämpfung es wird dort je nach
bundesland je nach parteizugehörigkeit
je nach gusto teilweise hat man das
gefühl entschieden die mit dieser
pandemie umzugehen ist da habe ich nicht
gefragt wer es nicht eigentlich besser
wenn der bund mal die pandemie
bekämpfung an sich ziehen würde der
bundestag könnte ja das
infektionsschutzgesetz entsprechend
ändern und dann dafür sorgen dass quasi
eine linie da ist die dann auch
durchgezogen wird damit nicht irgendwie
jeder landkreis beschließen kann oder
diese 100er grenze die rega war heute
nicht so genau
naja akademien die bekämpfung ist am
ende was was man auch sehr stark lokal
regional ja fast sogar lokal machen muss
schnell schließen schnell kontakt
nachverfolgung organisieren deutschland
ist in der tat besser durch diese zeit
gekommen als die zentral staaten
beispielsweise tschechien polen oder
auch frankreich wir sind unzufrieden ich
verstehe das auch die nerven liegen bei
uns blank aber ich würde mal sagen
viele wären froh wenn sie jetzt in der
aktuellen zeit solche zahlen hätten wie
die in deutschland dann müssen wir noch
mal über eine sache reden die für die
union nicht so richtig angenehm ist
gerade die massen affäre heute wurde
bekannt dass auch gegen den csu
landtagsabgeordneten alfred sauter
ermittelt wird wegen verdachts auf
bestechlichkeit im zusammenhang mit der
affäre nüßlein die unionsfraktion im
bundestag hat eine ehrenerklärung
abgegeben können sie für ihre
fraktionsmitglieder in sachsen
garantieren dass die sich nicht
bereichert haben ich kenne sie alle
ich würde für jeden einzelnen die hand
ins feuer legen aber sie müssen sehen
abgeordnete sind am ende ein
bevölkerungs querschnitt und so bitter
wie das ist es gibt leider auch solche
darunter die vielleicht nicht das gemein
allgemeinwohl als erstes sehen und es
ist wichtig dass solche sachen dann
aufgeklärt werden und konsequenzen
gezogen werden und warum sind die
geraden jahren sagt proportional
vertreten
ja sind sie nicht also wenn sie sich die
jahre zurückschauen dann fallen die
viele beispiele auch aus anderen
fraktionen ein oder aus anderen parteien
das wird es überall geben also es bitter
und das entscheidend ist wie man mit
diesen fällen umgeht ob man das
vertuscht
ob man das relativiert oder ob man mit
klarer kante da agiert und da finde ich
hat die bundestagsfraktion und ralph
brinkhaus das sehr klar gemacht und es
wird auch da dran geblieben
viel darüber gesprochen und zu recht ist
eine ganz bittere erfahrung
und dann gab es heute noch
rücktrittsforderungen von wolfgang
kubicki von der fdp gegen ihren
parteikollegen ganz sparen den
bundesratsminister hatte die pandemie
noch im griff
ich glaube schon also ich meine er hat
sehr viel geleistet in einer zeit da die
masken
raven versucht die dinge zu organisieren
meine ist es die aufgabe des
bundesgesundheitsministers masken zu
organisieren er hat es gemacht
also wurden sich eine andere dinge
geordnet
das hat auch gründe glaube ich da
anschauen ich habe auch solche beispiele
wir haben unseren polnischen nachbarn
damals mehr viel unterstützt und dann
kam auf einmal eine lieferung und keiner
hatte die zertifikate ganz am ende noch
schnell zurückgerissen weil wir gedacht
haben wenn wir jetzt nachholen masken
liefern die zwar wo zwei oben steht sp2
aber die haben keine zertifikat gekommen
teufels küche
also sind natürlich auch in dieser zeit
sie haben wir haben gerade über die
charakter von menschen gesprochen
auch leute dabei die wirklich mit dem
elend von anderen geschäfte machen auch
in der freien wirtschaft das ist schwer
nein es ist eine besondere
herausforderung ist eine
naturkatastrophe in der wie die wir
gestellt sind und sie geht sehr sehr
lange aus der geschichte wissen wir dass
die zweite welle immer größer ist als
die erste und die dritte größer als die
zweite und zwar deswegen weil die
menschen die kraft die nerven verlieren
und wir es droht uns so etwas ähnliches
wir werden auch in unserem urteil
zunehmend härter und ich finde auch
ungerechte es werden fehler gemacht ja
auch ich habe das gemacht aber es sind
alles menschen die versuchen das beste
zu bewegen und der
bundesgesundheitsminister hat furchtbare
tage nächte hinter sich hat das
menschenmögliche getan
auch mit unserer unterstützung er hat
viele weichen gestellt ist auch beim
thema testen und wir müssen diese probe
gemeinsam bestehen ich würde auch raten
dass wir jetzt nicht in den wahlkampf
modus übergehen sondern versuchen die
dinge zusammen zu halten das ist uns in
den letzten monaten eigentlich immer gut
gelungen
an diesem erfolgsrezept sollten wir
nicht jetzt scheitern oder ist aufgeben
letzte frage zum schluss da könnte man
macht ja job ein nicht gerade noch spaß
oder würden sie zwischendurch gerne
auswandern nach dubai zum beispiel ist
großen trend
wenn sie einmal sich auf den stuhl
gesetzt haben als bürgermeister als
landrat oder als ministerpräsident dann
können sie nicht weggehen sondern dann
müssen sie auch egal was ist bestehen es
ist schwer sind schlaflose nächte
ich habe das über den jahreswechsel
erlebt das verbindet mich mit den
medizinern und den pflegern in den
krankenhäusern im pflegeheim
es war furchtbar möchte so etwas nie
wieder erleben deswegen kämpfe ich jetzt
auch dafür dass wir einen guten weg
machen aber ich möchte nicht auswandern
ich liebe dieses land und ich finde das
ist eine schwierige zeit aber auf der
anderen seite auch bei gesundem
menschenverstand und bei ruhe
auch sieht man ja wege wie man sich
bewegen kann also lassen sie uns die
gemeinsam gehen und nicht nur aus dem
rückspiegel immer leben sagt michael
kretschmer cdu präsidiumsmitglied und
ministerpräsident von sachsen ich danke
ihnen dass sie heute abend so viel zeit
für uns hatten sie haben mit sicherheit
auch noch sehr viele andere termine zu
tun und daher vielen dank für die
beantwortung unserer kommentare unserer
fragen und ich sag auch zu euch vielen
dank fürs zuschauen fürs kommentieren
wie immer sorry dass ich nicht alles
mitnehmen konnte das ist nicht immer
einfach ihr habt viele detailfragen auch
gestellt aber ja ich habe versucht
mitzunehmen was geht
ich schaue noch mal rein was eure
stimmung ist geht so würde man so sagen
also war schon mal besser wir hoffen das
beste halten die ohren steif ansagen bis
zum nächsten stream morgen geht es schon
wieder gleich weiter
bis dahin macht gut sind dann fürs zu
sehen und schüsse